millions of people start to search for
Black Friday bargains online some are
being targeted by scam artists Americans
spent more than six billion dollars
online on Black Friday last year that's
a lot of money our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Warner
has been looking into some of these
schemes good morning to you Anna how are
people getting ripped off now
well good morning you know the scams
come in many forms one popping up more
and more is fraudulent websites that
look exactly like the real thing for big
names like Apple Amazon Walmart they're
good enough to trick you like the one
that tricked a Massachusetts woman who
says she never thought she'd fall for
something like this I looked up my
sneakers Hoka awry he's sighs and just
did a big google search Maureen Lambie
says when she went shopping for new Hoka
running shoes this site offered
discounts so she ordered a pair for the
bargain price of $80
it said Hoka Hoka e store.com so I
thought it was a hocus tor that was
until she checked her bank account where
she says she found two debit card
withdrawals one was the price of the
sneaker and one was another price but
they both come from they came from China
two days later the fraudsters made two
more withdrawals which she says totaled
about $350 Lambie fell victim to a scam
website in this holiday season there
will be more you definitely should not
feel bad if you fall for something like
this this happens to millions of people
three fouler at Consumer Reports writes
about digital security and scammers so
what are their new pitches this time
around you know it's a lot of charities
you know getting people to give it's
great sales rock-bottom prices and then
you know getting people to go to a site
that looks just like what you think is
the actual site like that fake Hocus
site Lambie visited where our deeper
dive showed some tip-offs reviews that
are actually for coats not shoes and an
email for a supposed customer service
site which an online reviews people
called fake Fowler showed us a delivery
failure notification hoax
look at the email here this is not a
legitimate FedEx validator app dot Asia
yeah I mean that that's the biggest red
flag ever and this $25 gift card offer
for iTunes says download all yeah that's
a very bad idea never click on
attachments never download things
they're very good at what they do
Steve Ginty with cyber security company
risk IQ says scammers want your personal
information like debit card numbers to
access your bank account as protection
he suggests using payment systems like
Apple pay venmo or PayPal for purchases
because you don't have to enter the
credit card information at time of
checkout and therefore the actors can't
get access to that information because
it's a secure transaction glammy got
most of her money back but she's still
out $80 and instead of shoes what showed
up in the mail from China a cheap
knockoff Gucci scarf she never asked for
and I feel bad for people like if
they're going out shopping for their
kids it's me it's sneakers III it's ok I
mean but people people like who maybe
they're buying their kids that Christmas
presents and then they don't get them I
mean that's even more so it's it's it's
pretty pathetic well ho chi told us it
has a team that combs the internet for
unauthorized websites and tries to do
everything in its power to protect the
consumer Lamy says her bank credited her
debit card for three of the four charges
but wouldn't correct her credit heard
the initial charge for the sneakers I
guess they thought that was technically
an approved transaction got a very cheap
looking Gucci scarf good rule never
enter your credit card for something
that you yourself are not ordering I
really like that tip from risk I know
jizz instead of shopping and entering
your credit card which a lot of us
including me have a tendency to do
either use a site like Amazon where it's
pre entered and you just click right so
the credit card you're never entering it
or you can use PayPal venmo one of the
services that already have the payment
and so you're using a third party so
that people you're buying from aren't
seeing that credit card yeah right
that's a very good tip yeah thank you
and and you know I always try to do a
little research and follow the you know
follow the website and see yeah you
should try to go to the research go to
Google try to find the author
website really look at the website name
yeah it's a tip-off all right Anna
thanks